c'est ouvrir ta grande gueule sur le
garçon je suis désolé qui es-tu oh si j'avais des
ailes et non c'est
fait  musicien,
je n'emprunte pas d'argent, ne pensez-vous
jamais à l'avenir du tout, vous voulez
dire comme déménager en banlieue, avoir des enfants,
c'est mauvais si c'est là que la musique est pour que
vous vous rendiez à cet endroit et oui
c'est un peu carriériste et  c'est un
petit carré c'est un peu triste de
ne pas chanter avec un chat est-ce que cela fait partie de
votre acte chaque fois que vous jouez un do majeur
dans vomir une boule de poils Je me souviens d'un
soir la pluie battante
mon cœur était une douleur douloureuse Freddy façon
salut chéri
eh bien il n'y avait pas d'avance sur mon
disque solo il doit y avoir de la royauté non
Mel je ne fais rien qui vaille la peine de vivre
sans celui que tu aimes
et le jazz tu sais on joue toutes les notes
12 notes de la gamme pas trois accords
sur un narguilé je sais pas  si vous gagnez votre
vie, plus de pouvoir pour vous de toute façon
et mon chéri fandi